[Music]
while an island off the coast of
Scotland something was summoned from the
depths of hell
[Music]
something that would end mankind the sir
thing he worried about to show up
oh yes
you did
we face every breath there is and yet
you take me in
hello something made me a goddamn weapon
where's my [ __ ] bye there
listen up ladies and gentlemen out there
there's a fifth-century sorceress who
was a bring down the curtain on London
and the world
great homework
why do you fight for those who hates and
fear you you are Mentalist
out of the ashes
okay I'd appreciate a prophecy with more
relatable stakes we've got to be saving
the world or something
okay do you see something
yeah call the suitors
[Music]
be my game
[Applause]
belong together human time
we do but it's not gonna work you know
cuz I'm a Capricorn and you're [ __ ]
[Music]
he warned us that something was coming
if there is ever an end in this forever
war it will be because of you and your
strong right hand where the line in the
sand we fight against the forces of
darkness this is the we're expecting a
sign that says secret headquarters oh I
need some ID love um are you serious you
made me a damn weapon I just wanted to
help you become the best you
[Applause]
some dads get their kids Legos saving
the world or something
does it do anything special yeah
it smashes things real good
[Music]
you are mankind's best and only hope
especially fighting monsters not working
with them do you call it monster
polymerase Lee
Ross
these are just some time
[Music]
[Music]
you